by the time I was 12 I was doing
stand-up comedy I read this she was
doing stand-up comedy at bar mitzvahs
that started at bar mitzvahs when I was
11 and 12. what kind of jokes are you
telling a kid's bar mitzvahs remember
folks you're 13 when you have a bar
mitzvah yeah well you would you do bot
Mitzvahs or just stick to the apartments
bar and but benign
okay that's the plural is that yeah okay
good
um uh the uh the jokes I would do were
probably five percent my own which were
not terribly funny but then 95 percent
the grade A material of one uh Richard
Jenny may he rest in peace um also
quickly yeah Lisa Kudrow I know she told
you to get an agent and start
auditioning yeah do you still talk to
her occasionally uh every time I've seen
her we've always had a lovely
interactions yes and yes that's true
when I was uh 12 years old she saw me do
stand up at a friend's Bar Mitzvah asked
me if I was a professional I said no
she's like oh you should consider it I
was like okay how do I do that she's
like buy backstage you'll find an agent
you'll you'll and that's what you did
and I literally bought backstage and
there was a manager advertising are you
a kid who does stand up so I called and
that's my rep who wound up years later
submitting me for Freaks and Geeks you
they're not with him anymore uh no but I
adore him right uh uh but uh yeah no
that was Sid gold the great Sid gold the
great Sid gold uh and uh yeah so thanks
Lisa